you
[Music]
over the past 30 years the films of Ken
Burns have covered the civil war the
Vietnam War baseball jazz and more his
latest project chronicling the story of
country music from the hollers of West
Virginia to the fields of California may
be his most emotional we sat down with
Byrnes this week here in New York then
one of the film's stars in Nashville to
look beyond any current definition of
country music and uncover its true roots
[Music]
country music has never gotten the kind
of comprehensive treatment you're about
to see what was it about that one moment
when you said I have to do this I
suddenly realized that this would be
American history firing on all cylinders
but just great stories defining country
may be impossible but what is possible
is tracing its roots back to America's
coming-of-age
from the Fiddler's and the banjo players
to Jimmie Rodgers and his yodeling
burns over the course of more than 16
hours and eight days explores the highs
and lows of country's history gene
Autry's singing cowboy Dolly Parton's
breakthrough and the meteoric rise of
Garth Brooks
[Music]
at the heart of so many of the stories
is the Carter Family starting with the
Carter Family Singers in the 1928 are
junk Artur and Johnny Cash's marriage
created a dysfunctional dynasty that
affected nearly every corner of country
music's future my dad he worked out all
of his problems on stage that's where he
took his anguish and fears and griefs
and he worked him out with an audience
that's just who he was instead of
focusing on historians in this
documentary Byrnes went straight to the
musicians legends like Merle Haggard
Kris Kristofferson and Marty Stewart the
thing I love about this all the sudden
country music in the 21st century is
also now elevated thanks to Ken Burns is
this a reset for country music I think
so
Stewart is country music's unofficial
record keeper a man trained by Lester
Flatt Bill Monroe and Haggard in cash he
was the person who guided Byrnes and his
lead writer Dayton Duncan more than
anyone else he saved every scrap of
paper every telegram every photograph
every uniform he knows the history back
and forth and he in the course of it has
seen everything
we met Stewart in Nashville where his
famous mandolin is its own piece of
history Bob Dylan Ricky Skaggs Chet
Atkins BB King Charlie pride so what was
it that grabbed you at such an early age
and didn't wanna go to New York I didn't
go to LA I want to go to Nashville and
play country music because those stories
that I heard Johnny Cash sing me and
Johnny western sing me those stories
that they sang there was like folk
heroes talking to me you got to
[Music]
one thing often ignored or misunderstood
in the history of country music is the
influence of african-americans
everything in America every
manifestation is never a one thing
because it's America it's a many things
it's an alloy stronger by that
combination so country music is itself
born in as much african-american history
as it is in what we think is sort of
white rural southern history so many of
these musicians had black mentors yes I
think a lot of people don't understand
that you let's take the Mount Rushmore
of of early country music and say ap
Carter of the Carter family I'd put up
there obviously Hank Williams obviously
Bill Monroe the inventor of bluegrass
obviously Johnny Cash no those four men
all had african-american mentors also
covered another sometimes sideline part
of country's history the woman's role in
country music
you can never diminish that you pull out
Loretta and Patsy and Connie and Dolly
there there's a vast void in the story
of countries well maybe not after this
series I hope not
we tend to in in the way we categorize
country music we denigrate it it's never
been given the respect it deserves and
so you know we don't think it's got the
same chops as jazz or blues or rhythm
and blues or rock and roll but yet in
the mid 60's Loretta Lynn is singing
don't come home a drinkin with lovin on
your mind
[Music]
nobody in rocker focus singing that
that's way ahead of anybody else no
she's not gonna call herself a feminist
but she's speaking for women and their
aspirations and their frustrations
better than anyone else
[Music]
if you rat the truth and you rat in the
song and you're sitting here right about
your life is gonna be country Loretta
Lynn singing about motherhood and birth
control was as honest as it gets a
canvas covered cabin
and it crowded labor camp
so is Merle Haggard talking about what
it was like to grow up in a family of
Okies migrants from the Dust Bowl who
went to California during the Great
Depression where they were seen as a
lower-class Haggard died in 2016 but
spoke to Burns at length before he
passed the human being has a history of
being awful cruel to some something
different
Merle Haggard is distilling all of that
pain and suffering and channeled it into
poetry that all of us can identify with
country music is about love and loss I
think so and if you think about the
great songs you know Johnny Cash at my
door the leaves are falling cold wild
wind
[Music]
I wonder if she's sorry for leaving what
we begun there's someone for me
somewhere because I still miss someone I
mean can't beat it you cannot beat it
[Music]
three chords and the truth
let's a country music so of the more
than 100 people that Ken Burns talked to
for this documentary 20 have since died
including Merle Haggard which makes it
historically an even more important
document yeah which is why it's all been
donated now to the Country Music Hall of
Fame and Museum he doesn't deal with any
music any country music from the past 25
years because as he says he's a
historian and we don't know where the
placement of all those folks currently
singing might be it takes time to get
there and there's so much to deal with
from the 1920s to the 1990s that's 16
hours right here 16 hours Plus this is
what surprised you walk in it is heavy
so you go in it is powerful and whether
you're a country music fan or not or
think you know country music it is worth
checking out learn some if that's
exactly it I love Loretta Lynn when you
write about the truth about life it's
country if you're writing about truth
and a song